i've known you for a long time you were
from kansas and uh
and and you moved here when you were
what quite young right well just getting
started in the business yeah i mean the
first time i lived
here i was a little kid then i then i
moved to kansas i was when i was 10.
i then decided to try and be an actor
and i moved out here when i was 20.
okay and uh it was pretty it was pretty
rough there
i have to say i had the experience of
moving out here when i was 22
and it was like going to the moon yeah
you know i was just getting started in
the business
and not having any idea like not really
having
a real job yet and not knowing what i
was going to do and being freaked out
was it like that way for you yeah i mean
i had a i had a
school that i was in that i was able to
go to for a little while but you do have
no money and you're really
you don't i don't i didn't know the
areas i was living in a very strange
place i didn't have a bed uh for for a
while what do you mean you didn't have a
bed i just didn't have a bath
yeah i didn't even have i started
crashing at a friend's house because i
didn't i
couldn't afford rent i laid down a bunch
of towels
i slept on about five towels for a while
and then i got my and then i got a
apartment i was able to get an apartment
in the
complex and actually found a mattress
in the dumpster in the carport and i
thought
sweet free mattress so i
hauled it up to my new apartment slept
on it woke up the next morning covered
in red bumps
but i kept it it no you didn't that's
when anyone else
burns it i think clearly there's a
vermin there's
vermin i think i sprayed it with lysol
and then i just like meh
and because when you're 20 you're just
like and then
and then eventually just the bumps went
away
wait a minute what do you do for food if
you have no money for could you get
groceries there was a place there was a
place and this is true there's a place
next
right next door call uh i won't say the
the restaurant because i could be sued
it was terrible
and it was all you can eat chinese food
for two dollars and fifty cents
oh my god i used to take my backpack
filled with tupperware
as if i couldn't even afford two dollars
and fifty cents every day and i would go
to the
food bar that looked like a rainbow
trout there was so much
msg sprinkled on top of it uh and i
would put it in these
tupperware bits and then stuff it back
in my backpack and heat it up
for to eat the next day but i would eat
so much of it one time i ate so much of
it i got up to leave and fainted
he's an msg shock my roommate beau and i
or my
he lived in the complex boat and we i we
would laugh
we would eat so much we would just start
hyperventilating and laughing
i mean what are we doing to ourselves we
get dessert and then go back for like
mushu pork
and then i remember laughing and then
getting up
and i fell back and the last thing i
remember
seeing was my friends face
reaching for me and then i kind of came
to and he had fallen over he was
[Laughter]
laughing